what you're seeing here is a world first
potentially life-saving treatment a part
of the picture
which could help bring us back to some
normality it's an antibody cocktail
specifically designed to protect people
from covid19
just that glimmer of hope that we're
going to get back to some kind of
normality and get out again
karen an intensive care nurse in
yorkshire is the first person on the
planet
to receive it i think it's really
important because we're there we're
around it all the time
and i know i'm not the only person from
our unit that's signed up for this so
you know it's a good thing and we're
sort of being we're being role models
i guess in a little way professionally
i've obviously seen the the impact that
kovitz had
over the last since march working back
in intensive care with both waves so
professionally i've seen the
devastation really that it's caused for
patients and their relatives
i miss my friends i miss going out for
my monthly
meals with my girls and hugging my girls
and anything i can do to get
back to some kind of normality i'd do it
this antibody injection which is set to
be fully rolled out next year
offers an alternative to those in whom
the vaccine won't work
vaccines usually work by pushing the
immune system to create its own
antibodies
to fight off infection but this may not
work for the sick
or elderly who have a weakened immune
system
the antibody treatment gets around that
by putting antibodies
straight into the recipient it's hoped
that protection will be instant
and lasts between six months and a year
we can't understand the importance of
this
i mean any interventions to help us
again in the fight against kobe that
are hugely important and we've had the
fantastic news just in the last week
around the
um the effectiveness of the the vaccines
but the reality is that
there will be some of the population
that won't mount an antibody response to
those vaccines so this is just another
and potential intervention to help
across the uk there are nine sites
working rapidly
in the final stages of trialing this
drug 500 people will receive it
whilst another 500 will think they've
been given it
so medics can work out its full
effectiveness the next stages
will see it rolled out in care homes and
even prisons
this type of passive immunity
won't ultimately make the big difference
uh for the control of the epidemic what
it will do
is enable us to protect particularly
vulnerable
sections of society the sort of people
who if they got the infection
would almost certainly have very severe
disease and have a much higher chance of
dying
the financial cost however is high just
one dose
costs over 450 pounds it's why they'll
administer millions
instead of billions but this is yet
another glimmer of hope
another piece of our armor in our fight
against covid19
and people like karen her colleagues and
many other millions of vulnerable people
can be protected from this disease which
has consumed our lives
in zaman rashid sky news in wakefield